i have cried twice in my life
once when i was seven and i was hit by a
school bus
and then again when i heard that little
sebastian had passed
his memory
will live on
as today we light a fire
that will burn on for eternity oh my god
[Music]
you're right
i am an addict i've hurt all my friends
and family with my addiction i will
accept this gift of rehabilitation i'm
proud of you but also a bit fearful that
we're verging on what i call feelings
territory
so let's stare at the fire in silence
every year i give leslie the same
present i give everyone a crisp 20 bill
and every year she gets me
something thoughtful and personal
it makes me furious
this year she outdid herself
she had it installed over the weekend
so oh my god
they they just forgot to unlock the door
that's all
ron
it looks like they're closed
some kind of health code violation
stop it ron
they just boarded her up like she was
some common warehouse
i should have been here
what happened to the stakes that were in
there when they closed
do you think they got eaten
why don't we go back to my place and
i'll fire up the grill you sure you're
not expecting company or something no
you say ron go back to my place and make
you some grub it'll be just as good as
it would have been here
okay
ron is making the model and then we're
gonna put all of our candy decorations
in our corners of the office okay so
what did everybody make boom
rock and roll candy andy wow that's
really good son i didn't do anything for
my office it's okay i took care of it i
made a marshmallow ron swanson
gosh his arms are crossed because he's
mad at all the other marshmallow workers
for annoying him
you like it
it's fine
i can handcraft 17-foot canoes out of
western red cedar but i can't glue two
damn graham crackers together look it's
really easy
i know a lot about candy
i play with it i eat it sometimes i play
with it and eat it
[Music]
okay new plan everyone else makes this
candy house and i make myself useful
elsewhere
crying acceptable at funerals and the
grand canyon
foul
foul on number three for taking a number
two on number four
roughing the passer double dribbling
that's a foul that's a foul for touching
the basketball what are you gonna do
about it nothing you fouled you can't do
anything okay
you're rejected you're ejected
oh what's the matter there iran no
players left
[Applause]
come on now you're openly cheering for
the other team put my boys back in you
made me the ref deal with it you know
what take this uniform off oh you don't
deserve to wear it
rhymes ejected from less than the rev oh
yeah i'm ejected what are you doing
i'm ejecting you you're ejected too
everyone's achieved
yeah
i was shot in the head with a shotgun
ron it's actually not that serious i
just need you to stay calm okay yeah i'm
just gonna stay angry i find that
relaxes me hey okay how are you feeling
how are you feeling are you dizzy dizzy
are you light-headed when i look at my
palm i see a lady's mouth french kissing
a dog
is that normal
well the pain medication i gave you is
pretty strong donnie uses it for
menstrual cramps how many did you take
seven eight
better wash them down with plenty of
fluids no ron you cannot drink scotch
with this you're gonna need to purge
right now okay
oh yeah no i'm not wasting 20 years yes
can you open his mouth leslie what open
his mouth no open his mouth okay i'm not
making myself throw oh ryan you're sorry
we have to do this let's roll around
good i will bite you roll in your mouth
grab this mustache open your mouth
dear ron
you have now reached the cliffsides
overlooking the islands
as you sit here and gaze upon the waters
please read out loud the poem by the
great scotsman robert burns love leslie
a worm i love yon lilac fair with purple
blossoms to the spring
and i a bird to shelter there
when wearied on my little wing
how i would mourn when it was torn
by autumn wild and winter rude
but i would sing on wanton wing
when youthful may it's bloom renewed
[Music]
i don't know what she thought i'd get
out of that
[Music]
ron
ask me if i'm sad
no
ron i found some towels
you okay
wow apparently craig is studying yoga
these are the only dry clothes i could
find well you look great i feel
extremely angry oh come on stop whining
you big baby i've seen you with your
eyebrows blown off i've seen you without
a mustache i've seen it all there's
nowhere to run ron you have tried every
possible means of escape there's nothing
to do but talk
what happened to these workplace
proximity associates
hmm
spill it
you left
then a month later you took terry with
you yeah well we needed a mindless fact
totem and he's the best there is amen
then you took april
i didn't want her to go as she had
become one of my closest workplace
acquaintances
but your offer was too good to pass up
so i didn't try to stop her
then tom left to run his business donna
left to run hers
one day i looked up
just didn't recognize anyone
so i made a decision
an unthinkable decision
hey
well my my my do my eyes deceive me is
that ron swanson hello leslie
hello april larry uh it's terry now okay
as luck would have it oh did you talk to
randy about the vote tell the northeast
that we need to put pressure on them or
else we're gonna be waiting for everyone
i'm tired of waiting on them okay sorry
this is a crazy day so what's up with
you you big lug nothing important just
thought you might want to have lunch
uh tomorrow i would love to it's been
too long
jj's diner 12 30. excellent see you then
okay so randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in washington
to prep oh my god really okay get us the
first flight out of here and grab the
missouri files meet me at my car
hey babe i got to go to washington
can you pick up the kids
oh oh no ron i stood you up for lunch
you did yes
i waited for a while but it was pretty
easy to figure out what had happened
your life seemed pretty hectic
is that the rest of the story that i
stood you up
you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch
ron you were going i was going to ask
you for a job
in the federal government
just saying it out loud feels dirty
you missed your friends
and you wanted to come up to the third
floor and work with us again
i can't even imagine how hard that must
have been for you
god why didn't i see that
ron i am so sorry
i should have been a better friend to
you honestly leslie it's fine
it was a punctuation mark on a sentence
that had already been written my time in
government work was over
i'm sure i love shutting things down and
bleeding the rotting beast from the
inside your metaphors are so beautiful
but it was time for me to leave and i
didn't feel like explaining why to you
or anyone
everything that happened after
the fight we had not given you a heads
up when my company took on the
morningstar development and
bulldozed the nurse's old house
i do regret that
i had a good run here
but after you and
tom and donna and april and terry left
when i looked around this office
nothing was the same
you